so uh Britney Spears is Catholic Britney
Spears is Catholic yes this is
incredible I knew that as soon as he
brought it up Sheamus was going to be
like oh yeah he's gonna start
high-fiving everybody oh we got a white
pill today I'm actually really happy to
hear this no I'm really happy to hear
this I learned about it on social media
the other day and lamentably never
brought it up on the podcast I don't
know why what happened she just posted
about how she's Catholic now and she
just got back for math so good for her
I'm very
very happy I really do think that is
that that is good for especially
everything she's been through with her
family and all this Insanity I've been
playing a lot of Rim world and in the
game if you put someone in like a dark
cage and they have a psychotic break
sometimes they'll have a shift of Faith
thanks buddy
maybe that's what she just experienced
wow I've got to say I support the free
Britney movement and stuff I think that
you know what's happened to her is
terrible but I've been so frustrated
watching Republicans like clamor to
defend Britney Spears when we have
political prisoners who are sitting in
jail since January 6th we have Julian
Assange sitting in prison we have all
these political prisoners and they're
like free Brittany guys yeah but I think
we're like we were talking about like
unborn children being killed but then
also you care about animal rights I
think I think The Unborn children thing
is significantly more important but that
doesn't mean it's wrong for you to be as
informed as you are about Peta I
remember back in 2018 when I said
Republicans were too stupid to deal with
social media censorship to save their
own careers also and like all these
Republican voters are like yes like the
Republican party what do they do no it's
amazing it's like Ilan Omar can come out
and win word vomit all over a group of
people and then the Democrats are like
well now let's not be too hasty and then
Marjorie Taylor green posts something
before getting elected and they're all
like what stripper of her her committees
and punish her because the Republicans
are losers yeah there's like there's a
couple of them you know what's funny I
was thinking about Rhino like you know
people call them rhinos yeah Republicans
name only but they but they'll say like
oh Mitch McConnell's a rhino I'm like no
he isn't he's exactly the Republican
party oh bro that's so true Rand Paul
Thomas Massey they're the ones who stand
out yeah that's very true no you're
right you're right I got to give that to
you yeah they're the ones who are like
this was our path in to actually affect
real positive change Republican party
doesn't do anything they just I don't
know sit in their hands
yeah and then they attack the ones who
do try to do anything yeah well this is
the creator they're the the you know we
like to say that they're the speed bump
for the Democrats but they're more like
The Gatekeepers making sure that nobody
gets in the way and allows the Democrats
to do whatever they want yes exactly
welcome to the unit party yep well this
is the thing too because a lot of people
I know on the left tend to not like the
Democratic party either I basically
don't know anyone who likes their
political party I agree frankly uh and
maybe that's just because I wouldn't
hang out with someone who did like their
political party and so it's a sampling
bias uh Libertarians libertarian party
Libertarians don't like the lp they've
been pretty big
when I was libertarian I hated the lp
the whole time I do I'm not a fan
but the mises caucus exactly yes Dave
Smith they're the only good thing as far
as I'm concerned
watching their pro-life watching Dave
Smith on Fox News is just amazing when
he debates leftists and they're like
Donald Trump and he's like I didn't vote
for him I don't like him I love it he's
like I think Trump is a war yes
he's like yeah he does they can't these
tribalist established people can't
handle it they're like I don't you you
you're clearly a trump supporter it's
like no because the libertarian we're
not you know what I mean that's what
they're saying yeah that that's actually
given me some uh you know I don't know
white pill I guess you can call it but I
guess the bigger question is whether or
not the libertarian party can pull off
any victories I really think it would be
an incredible thing if we had at least
one libertarian Party candidate in the
in in the house or something like that
that's my point I don't really
I don't really want them in well it's
complicated here's the thing I've said
this before my whole voting strategy is
vote for the most pragmatic pro-life
candidate possible and it gets difficult
when the libertarian party's involved in
a national election and they split up
the vote but honestly I think local
elections are unbelievably important if
not more important and if you've got a
pro-life libertarian again even though I
don't consider myself libertarian
anymore oftentimes they're going to be a
better option than a republican now of
course again you get into this issue of
splitting up the vote but that's not
always the case and it depends
Libertarians I don't know Libertarians
no I don't like Libertarians at all so I
think that they they're they're good on
foreign policy and stuff like that but
we have a massive crisis with the
culture domestically right amen and
they're like let people be as degenerate
as they want some of them are like the
hopians though Story Hour yeah as far as
I'm aware of the hopping and like the
mises caucus people are not like that
again I'm not liberating anymore yeah I
support the the mises
well so in general I'm not a fan of
Libertarians basically libertarian party
is a disaster yeah and then some sane
Libertarians came out and they were like
we're gonna form a caucus because we're
not insane misus is a guy right yeah
saluted vanges so yes the I think too
much of libertarianism it's that Meme of
the Fox right you know the scraggly
looking Fox and it's like that's what
libertarian ideals is the beautiful Fox
right the candidates are all like
scraggly and weird the majority of them
are open borders they support allowing
things like drag queen Story Hour oh
I've seen a lot of them supporting CRT
and I mean yeah those people those
people are idiots yeah like you're great
on foreign policy cool but like we have
some problems here right now so I hear
you yeah but but you can be libertarian
and be opposed to those things and
that's the problem with Libertarians
they ruined libertarianism you know well
the party the party itself the party is
garbage it's terrible so if you guys
want like libertarian party people
elected I have to disagree no well
that's what I'm saying if you had good
people like like from the mises caucus
in the party who are actually gonna
stand up against the federal government
when they try to impose these lockdowns
on their County which I think
Libertarians in the mises caucus would
be far more likely to do than
Republicans then I would say okay that's
a good person to vote for yeah but if
we're talking about these sort of milk
tea milk toast people who are in favor
of garbage like CRT and say like drag
queen Story Hour is just the right yeah
you have a right to like force your
perversion onto children take his
clothes off on stage yes yep yep that
did happen what is this that indeed can
we get sane liberty-minded individuals
well we we do I think with music caucus
but yeah I think
um the problem is there are a lot of
anarcho-capitalists they're absolutely
on on board with all that stuff now that
they're on board with it okay yeah
they're really weird about the age of
consent stuff too I like really don't
like them I don't know you can be on the
libertarian spectrum and want individual
freedoms and Liberties while recognizing
we need standards yeah I mean like we I
don't I don't want the idea of the
scraggly degenerate you know Fox
libertarian ruining the idea of
respecting individual liberties and
being in Liberty side you know the
problem is people who are for Liberty
tend to be more individualist and don't
organize Yep they're like leave me alone
I'll do my thing and then what happens
right everything goes insane and the
lunatics they often don't get into
politics I can't bring myself to do it I
think it's technology is the way if you
really are liberty-minded sane
individual you should be building
technology that will help solve like
social media algorithm problems you know
shipping and materials so that we can
get drone deliveries organized all over
the world
we're not going to write our way out of
this with politics
what's up I had an MRE earlier how was
it was pretty good salty people were
eating yeah yeah because they're because
they're fun it's like Lunchables for
adults because you eat one last night
too
um I think I think I know maybe I did
there's like an open one on the bar I
may have yeah it's a lot of stuff yeah I
had tuna I had Tuna the Tuna was good
what made you think of it I don't know I
just burped oh yeah
that's good that means you're digesting
hey earlier when I said that uh
psychotic break can make you have a
crisis of faith I wasn't saying that
it's psychotic to be Catholic I was
being I was being Sergeant I'm saying
that guy when people go through
psychotic breaks they they have shifts
of Faith sometimes maybe Brittany who's
been locked up and going insane all of a
sudden had a crisis of Faith or maybe
her faith was like Faith was something
she needed to get through that yeah
maybe because she wasn't Catholic before
right now she is is that I mean she was
Christian she she may have been a lapsed
Catholic or something like no she was
she also said she said I'm Catholic now
not like I'm taking my faith seriously
or so uh I assume she was not Catholic
before maybe maybe we need to start
thinking about things more like Vermin
Supreme did yeah let's go deeper on that
of just like absurdity to challenge the
system yeah organize absurdity organized
absurdity I like this idea
yeah I like the Andy Kaufman it's called
government already exists it's called
DNC so so here's a funny thing like uh
antifa used to be just just be called
the black block and it was a nebulous
term to ref it was just a reference to
the group of people who all wear you
know all black and garan's matching
stuff which is basically we call antifa
now and there were a lot of people like
trying to figure out how do you deal
with that they're like what's it what's
a counter to this because if you show up
and like you know fight with them
they'll call you far right or whatever
and I was like boom clowns yes clown
block
show up yeah yeah just for the sake of
entertainment to dance and sing and play
music and clap and and do uh that's how
you defuse the violence from these
extremists I just got a unicycle
imagine this imagine this antifa's going
like they're all smashing and screaming
imagine that and then like you know the
right wing groups show up and they're
fighting and they have Shields and
there's the news it's like oh no there's
clash in the street imagine instead a
bunch of clowns stood up and they were
they came with flowers and they were
dancing and happy and they were getting
in the way of the extremists and they
were going in between the Black Block
how are you going to say a bunch of
clowns the bad guys when they're there
with flowers and they're laughing and
playing music and dancing and everyone's
just like it breaks that violence apart
I I honestly I gotta say I think that
could stop a riot you see antifa going
out there and they're smashing windows
and screaming sending the clowns you
know what else to stop a riot if we put
all these people back into asylums bring
back Asylum
no I I'm a big fan of Exile
because it's a personal thing right like
if some if if they can't if Society came
to me and said what you're doing is
wrong and we want to lock you up for it
I'd be like can I take a boat and just
go off and do my own thing because I'd
rather do that I'd rather risk my own
yeah I think they banished uh Lenin from
Russia or from Soviet Union and they
banished Napoleon from France but they
both came back like worse than ever
Napoleon came back and started another
war and and so did Lennon came you know
I was thinking about this I'm like what
would we do for like healthcare reform
and prison reform and I was like we
should totally get rid of our prisons as
we know it and maybe just create like um
what do they do in Norway it's like an
island yeah it is they put everyone on
an island interesting and then like you
get limited resources and you're
basically responsible for yourself and I
I think there's a study that said they
actually found that it eliminated the
criminal Tendencies because people
started working together to survive good
for them and it you know I'm like maybe
that's a better way to do it instead of
having people in these institutionalized
you know penitentiaries where they're
not actually being rehabilitated they're
being institutionalized we let people
you know we obviously monitor health and
safety we don't we're not sending people
to an island just starve to death but
it's like your day is your day you're
responsible for yourself you can't leave
we won't let you but you're free to roam
as you please and there would be housing
and then it's just like there you go
we've we've removed the threat from
society and now you're off over there
doing whatever you want
I think they would form like militias
and and abused with no weapons and
you're surrounded by walls are they
allowed to like throw the pedophiles off
the buildings or what what's the deal
like do they have police no no like no
prison guards we're just wondering
cannibalism if you're a violent criminal
no there would be food they would give
them food if you're a violent Criminal
you then through due process you lose
some rights you lose many of your rights
and I think why should we spend so much
money locking them in these big
facilities desperately trying to contain
the threat instead of being like you
have forfeited you know the social
contract and we're gonna send you over
there and you can go do whatever you
want just not here with us yeah I think
it's prison exacerbates the problem a
lot of times they go sit there with
other criminals and a violent
environment what if we make them and
hear me out you know they're they're in
these tunnels and they stand on this
pedestal that raises them up and then
there's you know 20 23 other people and
there's in the middle a bunch of weapons
and they're in this big dome yes and
then the countdown happens and then
whoever survives in the end wins and is
called the Victor and then they can do
that every onto Society
I'm kidding by the way you earn your
freedom if you kill the most people you
earn your freedom oh that's like the
movie Gamer you've seen Gamers yeah I
like that movie with um Gerard Butler
that's the dude from 300. so is that
yeah he's amazing yeah the movie was
cool like my favorite actors of all time
oh they're bringing Dexter back oh yeah
they're filming it in Massachusetts wow
I'm kind of excited for that because
Dexter was awesome but it like ended you
know but the ending was bad yeah okay so
I'm kind of okay with the new new ending
did you see Suicide Squad
no because I am very still upset about
yeah what they did to Suicide Squad
is my favorite comic oh brutal partial
spoiler I'm not I'm not gonna spoil any
anything from the movie
but if you don't want to hear anything
about the movie then you're not going to
want to hear what I have to say my
critique of it
uh so you've been warned
hold on thank you
I didn't I didn't I didn't really enjoy
it I I'll say this I laughed a lot
um but I think I realized something
James Gunn doesn't have the magic Kevin
feige does and James Gunn has some good
ideas that when put through the Marvel
Studios filter make it made an excellent
movie but I was really confused as to
why they did Suicide Squad this one the
way they did now apparently it's getting
Rey reviews they did it they redeemed
themselves I'm like no they didn't no no
they didn't was uh Jared Leto in that
and then okay he he was apparently
didn't take that one very seriously I'm
really banned from Ever playing The
Joker ever I'm really really really mad
about something in Suicide Squad as soon
as this one thing happened I almost
turned it off why would you say this
yeah is this new the news yeah it just
came out
um uh came out like what is it like yeah
this morning like midnight oh yeah um
you were watching it yeah it's on HBO
Max dude I it's funny because I like
took my headphones off and put my
fingers in my ears but I was like wait a
minute because I hate having things
spoiled but I was like I'm never gonna
watch this wait a second I was I was
like the wheels on the bus go round and
round round and round as Tim's going on
about suicide squad I don't I I I don't
wanna I don't want to say it's too soon
to say spoilers I can't even talk about
spoilers it's too soon it literally just
came out so I'll have to wait you advise
people to go see it yeah yeah it was it
was it would I definitely think you
really have a fun time go to the movies
grab some popcorn and sit back the first
one
I okay I was amped for that movie I
bought it was sold out uh so I had
bought like three different showings of
it I got an outfit for it because I like
love Suicide Squad I love anything
involving the Joker and so I was amped
and then I went and saw it and I was
just like me and like five other people
that were random people that were in the
theater were screaming at it like and I
hate that guy I hate the person who
screams at the movie theater but we were
like throwing our popcorns it was that
it was who's your favorite Joker
um Joaquin Phoenix
so you like the northern Heath Ledger
yeah wow definitely
possible dude when I I definitely
enjoyed it but it's it's tough for me
when I watched Joker that last scene
where he's sitting there and he's
talking to you know what's his favorite
murder and he goes I'm the Joker baby
I'm I'm like on the edge of my seat and
I'm shaking like watching it like I like
my heart was racing I was like this is
amazing and it's well done it was for us
for a super villain and it was not your
typical super super villain I was just
like the ending blew me out of my scene
I saw it twice in a row opening night
the first one yeah my problem with it
was that there was no Batman there was
no villain in that movie it was called
Joker not bad like Batman would have
been the villain
actually Batman isn't it I mean Bruce
Bruce there is a villain there's Murray
there's uh Bruce Wayne yeah
I don't know I'd like to see why I play
The Joker in the Batman movie well
they're they're doing that would be cool
I agree in the flash Michael Keaton's
coming back I guess yeah Michael
Keaton's gonna be playing Batman in The
Flash movie which is awesome Michael
Keaton by the way also I think the best
Marvel villain to be complete Adrian
tombs did you guys see uh he was good
homecoming
it was one of the best of villains I've
seen in any of the Marvel movies he's so
real A working class guy doing cleanup
on a contract he already bought the gear
and then the the government comes in and
says you're out and he's like come on
guys like we already bought the
equipment like we got to pay this off I
got people to feed and they're like so
what and so he gets screwed over by the
government and he becomes this like
I'm gonna take whatever I have to take
kind of villain it was good it was good
yeah anyway the new Joker is based off
uh Bernie Getz did you guys know that
who really I didn't know that who was
all recently he was um he was a really
big case that the NRA had got involved
with
um he killed or he shot I don't remember
if he killed them but he shot some
people on the subway and was basically
like I'm sick of crime I took it into my
own yeah he was the Vigilant the subway
vigilante guy yeah sung about in uh We
Didn't Start the Fire by yes Billy Joel
who looks like Michael Keaton
it all comes together he doesn't look
like Michael Keaton I always thought he
did what ever since I was a kid in the
80s he looked up I thought they were
like that was back when the NRA had guts
anyway John Cena right John Cena and
Suicide Squad I thought was pretty good
oh I was I was really I thought it was
great he was he's funny he's good he's
good John Cena's great yeah that was
that was rad and Idris Elba pretty good
uh but I I was I almost turned it off
margarubia him yes she's like the face
of the movie basically just I just I
almost couldn't watch it I was I was
angry damn I was like I can't believe
they would do this YouTube but they're
making a new alien they're just abusing
these titles now it's true yeah man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time